[Music]
snap really does look good but terrible
map
it is ridiculous inferno because like
it's always gonna be one-sided
this was a massive gameplay problem with
the map that made it less fun to play
well i've inferno for a reason and i
guess we should make them happy
fryeburg does return picks off pronax
he's still here though and he's going
for more two big frags the third man is
here however and freiburg has to back
off but fryburg somehow opens it up once
see if there's another one he could kill
he spots both of them he gets oh my god
that is insane doesn't hit the nose go
doesn't hit the pistol
would you believe it oh this is huge
don't made it into the corner just as
the ball is going to go off they're both
going to go down
debris is like sweating bullets
he's going to get the quad kills
[Applause]
it's fair to say that inferno is the
most reputed and refined battleground in
competitive counter-strike it isn't the
franchise's most iconic locale that's
dust too but it is the most integral and
for better or for worse indispensable
guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
inferno is the definition of honest high
intensity hell in a cell counter-strike
it's chaotic claustrophobic and
painstakingly strategic the fact that
the sights are hard to take is only
offset by the fact that they're even
harder to retake kenny you know one
versus three and luminosity they are one
round away from match and matt point
here kenny getting a single headshot
he's got the double sprays gets one more
there's no goddamn way that he's going
to do this he's got no health call going
to go for it he gets the shot kelly what
are you enjoying you've got to be
kidding that's a clutch oh my god
inferno is our fabled franchise's great
equalizer it's also been around forever
you see this small rustic settlement
dates back to the dawn of counter-strike
itself created by christopher narby otty
the same map maker who made aztec and
vertigo d-e-inferno was first rolled out
on march 13th 2001 as part of cs 1.1 cs1
version was set in a village with the
bomb sites being areas next to gas
pipelines the terrorists seek to destroy
layout-wise is surprisingly similar to
the current inferno but visually it's
almost unrecognizable which is
understandable of course what separated
inferno from the fray is that even among
counter-strike's most primal
foundational play places it stood apart
as a sort of instant competitive classic
once they get up in a jungle it's kind
of just a massacre they're able to
really easily pick off that triple stack
the player in sight the player big pit
i'm not sure that the cts were aware
that ntw was so on to what they were
doing and how passive they were going to
be playing especially on such a low buy
round for them from the day it launched
to the tail end of 1.6 it was never not
a vital go-to stomping ground for
literally anyone who took this
inimitable shooter seriously engendering
all manner of slow strategic meticulous
slugfests
[Applause]
inferno was just as much about mind
games as it was about mowing people down
in 1.6 you can also hacks a lot of more
through shoot through the walls etc you
can do a lot of different spams you can
use your utility in a different way like
you can throw a grenade on the roofs and
then you can hear them like getting hurt
by the nades like you can you can clear
out way more different positions
on the map on infernal especially 1.6 it
wasn't until the addition of inferno
into source in 2005 however that it
really started to resemble the calm
rustic village that we know love and
trounce around in today fairy games need
to get that defuse if they want to get
themselves ahead again rpk takes on
shocks comes in smiz grabs two of his
own molok rpk again and again he takes
out smiz rpk and apex versus molok can
they do this one versus two molecules on
apex can he clutch this for uh dragons
comes in rpk says no and he rips his
head off comes in with the defuse from
graveyard to car to that god forsaken
boiler room it was in source that
virtually all of the hallmarks from
which inferno's now vestigial call outs
came to be ever wondered why they're
called first and second oranges it's
because they used to be filled with
actual citrus what's funny is that
although sources de inferno is
ostensibly situated somewhere in spain
the real life inspiration for this
revamped village is actually located in
california you see much of the map was
modeled after a city in orange county
known as san juan capistrano but it was
also in source that inferno's campiness
really started to stand out it was ratty
cramped filled with hiding spots and as
such impinged upon the element of
surprise rounds on inferno were either
slow and gruelling over in the span of
seconds or both
coming through apartment points he takes
down one two three as they line up
perfectly for him as they just jumped in
trying to take him down as he just
completely ripped them apart
that was huge right there nbk in the
meantime took down smiz over on the uh
right side but he's coming back around
and he's gonna be making his way through
the apartments uh i don't know where
shox is but he's gonna peek out and
nathan's gonna get dropped by shocks the
map's slow execute heavy play style
began to take root more than perhaps any
other map in counter-strike inferno
pigeon-holed you into hitting a sight
and hitting it hard the reason of course
is that inferno was all about rotates
the sights were easy to hold difficult
to assail and impossible to reassail
that said the journey through ct was
long meaning that the goal for teas was
either to fake and beta rotate or take
in seconds flat as they try to push
their way up into the a bomb site and he
just ripped them apart uh mouse boards
still pushing around trying to keep them
at bay rattlesnake takes on one
conan and angel does answer back on the
mx that's a nice shot there and uh bomb
is going to get planted it is now a oh
make that a 1v3 it was a 2v3 but angel
dust gets dropped it is now conan versus
mousesports and coming around coney gets
one on the release and pete he gets that
last one on the husie that was
absolutely awesome and then in 2012 the
world beheld the release of
counter-strike's true long-awaited
successor global offensive and with it
an even newer inferno alright so you're
now looking at inferno and the
counter-strike global offensive beta
obviously looks a lot nicer pretty big
visual upgrade over past counter-strikes
and that is where things really started
to heat up he's behind the sandbags and
they come for me gets the first kill now
it's a one on two and the bomb is
ticking away
he's cl he's kind of stoned out here and
that's not good he has to go back and
get a head shot and they're waiting for
it to get right and slow the bomb is
being defused flush against the first
kill he sprays through they stop
diffusing and it's a one-on-one flushes
out of bullets two left he goes down to
flaring but there's no time flusha did
it oh my god it's gonna be eleven or
four what a round with cs entering the
modern era and even weightier majors on
the line the competition really
stiffened since inferno was already
integral to high level play it quickly
evolved into this sort of ultimate
decider a must-have make or break moment
in any three-map throwdown and snax will
be the man that'll lead this push in and
he'll get a headshot on to get right and
they're four frags away from victory now
it's freiburg still in there though
freiburg's not gone
and he will show himself at the right
moment which is a head shot onto bialy
he will eventually go down at the hands
of patcher they're three frags away now
murders bro as they will move the bomb
in and it'll be fifth flared and exist
to come charging in and stacks to go
mowing them down one more we'll do it as
pro
it's all on forest he gets the first
he doesn't get the second man
a place where legends were not only born
but kings crowned thrown by a nip to try
and hold them back olefmeister will find
the shot on exist fryeburg does return
picks off pronax he's still here though
and he's going for more two big frags
the third man is here however and
frybrick has to back off but fry bark
somehow opens it up single-handedly all
three frags but the bomb is on the other
side
yeah but that could be all right fine i
think i'm making a huge rotation
freiburg all he has to do is stay alive
and it's gonna be great oh he picks up a
quad kill he could do even better than
staying alive he gets the kill now
is it gonna be an ace with five hp
that's what's on the plate right now for
freiburg jw on the other hand has quite
a different menu to chew through here
he's got a one-on-three with an awps
guess the right bombsite but the bomb
goes down so now he not only has to kill
three members of nip he also has to
defuse the bomb and i'm wondering if it
isn't smarter at this point trying to
find a way out but
from the depths
like a hungry shark just
inching his way forward here he wants
that ace and that would be absolutely
brutal financially that could really
rock then freiberg comes in he's praised
freiburg misses and has the ace he
breaks it up single-handedly
ruins fnatic from pretty much the second
that cs go started inferno began to
solidify itself as this essential
inseparable part of what made its
rapidly growing competitive scene tick
the one map that everyone not only
played but had a plan for since well you
had to inferno everything can change
just a matter of seconds if you tank
this nade too much
you may see out of the round if you're
not lucky enough to insta headshot
someone if you go into the air be
execute or execute that but
i know there's something with inferno
that like you said like people are
inferno for a reason and i guess we
should make them happy inferno wasn't
just a stomping ground it was a breeding
ground for what you ask everything
whether it was scandal he's the one with
the m4 he's still fully set up he does
catch a glimpse of one he gets the tag
he gets the kill oh how the hell did he
pull that off strategy five seconds
there's the bomb plant attempted could
they hear it i think the smoke actually
blocked the sound the bomb goes down
with two seconds left then that's gonna
be it sheer unadulterated hype has
pronounced
or something in between device he should
know he sees alois while he's wants to
see if there's another one he could kill
he spots both on him he gets oh my god
that is insane takes down elements
what a next level play inferno was proof
that if you took the greatest gunners
csgo had to offer stuck them into this
small cerebral hellscape and put their
tournament lives on the line anything
could happen kennys on site straight in
his face doesn't hit the nose go doesn't
hit the pistol
would you believe it to catch somebody
peak on envy's side and well that's what
happens when you go around the corner
happy with dig oh and another one oh and
a third
happy
he could get another one here too dupree
debris is like sweating bullets
he's gonna get the quad killing the ace
what is this
the downside to all of this of course
was that for those who were actually in
the match inferno was kind of a
nightmare it was tight offered very
little variety or breathing room and was
almost oppressively execution-centric
everyone was smoking top banana from ct
spawn all the time you were just waiting
for smokes and eventually the game would
end up in like
20 30 seconds and then everyone on a
could be sitting on spots you could
basically not kill them on and if you
went b
you basically got like three people in
your face directly and there you're
sitting there just waiting for you to
just have no names left and hope for the
best basically really wondering about
get right's position right now all the
way in the back there is the auto sniper
really going to be useful from this
position sure if they boost up like he's
expecting but if they get into the bomb
sign and they are walking in right now
he's looking for the shot here you can
see a couple of faces well there's the
one kill that's a good start here but
they're challenging them they're
fighting they're not scared get right oh
he gets all three kills looking for what
to sdh get right shutting it down and
it's 14 to 7. unlike most of csgo's
other competitive offerings inferno
wasn't open puggy and fluid it forced
you to adopt and ideally perfect the
sort of constricted cage-matchy
all-or-nothing style of counter-strike
whether you wanted to or not they are
forcing you to play a style that you
don't want to play and i feel a lot of
people don't want to play like that like
you have to be forced into playing a
different style or a specific style on
the map that gonna be make it or break
it basically like there's nothing
special with it but other maps you can
do so much more with it that's the thing
that's the beauty of cs like other maps
can give you more opportunity to do
other cool stuff in an effort to
modernize the map a little bit valve
afforded it with a much needed visual
and structural rework about midway
through 2016 one that removed and or
rectified a lot of its rattiness
securing its future whilst s3 clicks
philip shows us
paying tribute to its past hidden within
this room is a computer screen it's
usually off but
very occasionally
it's on and showing the menu of counter
strike 1.1 which happened to be when
inferno was first featured within the
game the issue of course is that one
couldn't simply undo the suffocating
enclosed and repetitive nature of the
map with the wave of a hand it seemed as
if inferno was fated to remain this
frustratingly formulaic set piece a
sentiment that war owl echoed shortly
after the rework the difficulty in
performing retakes on the map often led
to games where after the terrorists
captured a bomb site the cts just
decided to save even when they had equal
numbers where on a different map they
would have attempted a retake
statistically this happens more often on
inferno than any other map at both the
professional level and the matchmaking
level i don't think anything has been
done to mitigate this issue as the
general layout of the map remains almost
completely intact when the new inferno
was released i thought it was going to
skew more terrorist sided than the
previous version because it was more
difficult to do that smoke delay meta
that was so common previously also with
the wider passageways i thought it would
be easier for terrorists to push
positions they wouldn't get bottlenecked
as easily
that didn't happen it felt as if no
matter what the vast majorities of
rounds played out exactly alike the ts
had little to no freedom in their
movements and were obligated to tick the
same boxes every round
take banana control try for brackets
bait out utility pick a site and well
pray
every ct does the same thing as well
if they're the best pawn for top made
they're going to throw down a molly to
destroy them to not getting into close
to banana or peak mid at the same time
the b guys are trying to take b control
the terrorists are also throwing up
molotovs up in the car like close to the
car
or taking like hard controlled banana
and then all the suddenly the the a abs
guy died because someone lurked against
a or he kills the guy who's lurking
second bit like
it's it's nothing special with it it's
nothing like mind blowing with it
because we've seen it through like the
[ __ ] early station for the same thing
there you know like
it's sad in that way and yet here's the
thing about inferno in spite of all its
faults all of its annoyances since time
immemorial it's never ever not delivered
just changes could go either way but um
oh he's got the ankle right through the
smoke
absolutely beautiful and that's another
opening kill here that is what fanatic
need that's exactly what titan did as
well existence will get the return here
on crimson
titan right now actually have to be a
little bit concerned because the four
round difference here is not that great
this is within the realm where financing
could definitely make a comeback happen
oh certainly certainly they are
currently walking up onto the site but
i'm glad that they're all grouped up if
they can take this fight kelly doesn't
manage to pick up the entry though and
this is going to slow things down for a
fanatic and he's going to get into
position from pitt as well and this is
such a difficult position to get him out
of
this and they have a second member here
at the bomb sign and there's already a
rotation happening fnatic are actually
in a horrible spot right now
as long as titans stay cool they're
gonna be fine what a sick shot at oh my
god jbw he gets the second one he's
looking for the ac he's got just seven
bullets and he's gonna go for it in the
corner now it's a one-on-one he misses
that shot there's 25 seconds left and
he's got six health he's gonna go with a
c said sprays here assistant's trapped
in a corner now 20 seconds
are you kidding because when the going
gets tough and the stakes are as high as
can be there is no place you as a
spectator would rather be this setup is
getting torn apart lucas back in again
the third kill on the way through he
gets shut down but hobbits gotta find
two more angles
no plays you'd rather see bring more
this is
because counter-strike isn't always
about doing what you want it's about
doing what needs to be done nothing else
is going on he's got to go back stewie's
on his own but look at the time look at
the time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie's walking around we're going to
overtime
tom's going to do it
[Applause]
it's about feeling the heat and
performing in spite of it and suffice it
to say on inferno you always feel the
heat devices had a really rough game
flashed he's gonna get that shot and
that has to feel a little bit good out
middle of the air to take down alex and
now they're pushing
me takes every single one
from nothing to the awps
it's the one map in counter-strike where
there is quite literally no room for
error where oftentimes you need to pull
off some unthinkable [ __ ] simply because
you have no other option does breezy
actually get a plant oh no the creeks
are coming the creeks are coming oh wait
maybe more
no way
oh my goodness
where dreams don't just come true but
undone at the drop of a hat here with
the opener they're trying to chase
fallen down but stewie's got his back
it's the beginning of the end and it's
all the awps canadian burnout can't find
a thing still we have fallen making it
happen make it team liquid be that
semi-final he's three fresh as good as
he's been as much as he's given us
this is a team liquid victory team up
he's on for a third now i did as well
refresh how are you making this happen
grim the pit hero the guy who's dug deep
throughout this entire series to save
that a bomb site has now gonna come in
clutch and b
refresh on for the ace in a one on five
clutch he's looking to keep his legacy
in check this never should have happened
it should have never been this close
grim his heart's racing his heart's
beating but refresh can't find him it's
a guessing game stick on the bomb grim
doesn't swing he thinks it's a fake
refresh with all five and we're going to
overtime the unforgiving infernal
underworld where our game's greatest
scores are settled and for better or for
worse always will be inferno the
legendary map that's always played in a
good best of three was standing up
because the grand final map of the major
but we weren't really 100 sure that we
have the chance that we need one this
one but farmer made a huge chase i
remember one on three clutch
and we won
finally
they are
the champions for the second time pronax
with one freiburg oh my god he's free so
he gets both kills and the grand final
continues again on the side let's see
some more magic my friend with that orb
chris j goes down
and nifty is coming up absolutely insane
right now for the renegades
guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made it work clown
nine are your elite major champions
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our twitter
instagram facebook and tech talk
[Music]